nous mène en bateau donc un coup on fait
5 on ne fait pas ça on sait plus donc il
va nous dit confiné certes puisqu'il va
y avoir les élections il ya longtemps
que je suis plus les les informations à
la télévision parce que tout le monde le
dit blanc noir on sait pas trop où on va
alors je ne sais pas ce que ça va
apporter ce des combinés au maintien le
mans après toutes les mesures qu'on
longtemps de ça de sa bouche à bouche de
ces de ses ministres je ne fais plus
confiance à qui que ce soit c'est des
annonces qui sont ces ag si la gestion
n'est pas n'est pas bonne à mon avis
pour beaucoup de choses donc ont suivi
je crois qu'on est là que pour ça
j'attends qu'il soit clairement ce
qu'ils expriment
mais bon ça il le fait à chaque fois je
trouve
après on maintenant par rapport à un
déconfinement je pense que c'est trop
tôt pour moi je comprends que tout le
monde en a besoin parce que parce que
c'est difficile et que l'été arrive mais
je pense que c'est un peu trop tôt et
qu'on risque de se reprendre la même
chose
un épisode de ce style disons après
l'été indien coi ça ça me fait peur donc
j'attends des manuels macron que
qu'ils n'annoncent pas un déconfinement
en fait ou alors quelque chose de très
partiel moi je suis à la tente pas l'air
d'avoir des dates précises et voilà
après voilà après je vous dis que il
fait ce qu'il veut s'il qui peut et
parce que c'est pas facile pour vous non
plus et moi je le soutienne de tout mon
coeur parce que vraiment il est pas tout
seul et c'est très difficile
j'aimerais bien qu'on soit des confiné
ça c'est sûr parce que y'en a ras la
casquette
j'accueille nous disent que les bars et
les boîtes sont réouvertes voir sortir
avec mes copines ça me manque trop
franchement je pense qu'on attend toutes
et tous la réouverture des des voix
débat restera mais principalement des
restaurants et tout parce qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de convialité moins de
rencontres et pour la gérer les
générations d'aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué parce qu'on n'arrive plus à
parler les uns avec les autres même les
réseaux sociaux on est trop rogner trop
et du coup il ya plein de polémiques
qu'ici faut mais on est on est beaucoup
trop dans la technologie maintenant
alors qu'on aimerait plus vivre dehors
et se rencontrer dehors et partant de
partager des moments ensemble aller
faire les magasins
enfin que ça nous manque c'est un train
de vie qu'on a plus et franchement ce
serait bien de les récupérer
tout en gardant quand même dans la
sécurité et que le virus se propage pas
plus donc faudrait prendre des
dispositions adaptées propres pour pour
tous